I started to think about belief systems,
you know,
because you could say that each
camp had its own belief system.
The one in the West was derived.
It had a very lengthy history derived
from the Greeks and the Romans and Jews
and the Christians and,
and from various schools of philosophy
and from the enlightenment and all of
that.
And then the Soviet Union was basically
predicated on a rational philosophy that
that opposed the axioms that the West had
evolved and each group organized their
societies around that.
And,
okay.
No,
I took political science
for quite a long time.
Okay.
And the political scientists
and the economists,
they basically thought that
people competed over resources.
Um,
but that wasn't a very good answer as
far as I was concerned because it wasn't
obvious to me why people valued
the resources they value.
There was the economist,
just assume that there's
resources that you value,
but you know,
people can value a lot
of different things.
It's,
it's not exactly fixed.
I mean,
you tend to value food very
highly if you're hungry,
obviously.
But you know,
there's lots of things that we value
and that we want that seem somewhat
arbitrary.
Someone like a decision.
So I got more interested in why people
valued things and what it meant to value
something and then what it
meant to believe something.
And then how it could be that someone
could believe something so deeply that
they would risk their own death to
protect it or at least risk the death of
other people.
And maybe on a massive scale like man,
people are committed to their,
to their system.
Now,
you know,
a system of belief is not
just a system of belief.
That's one of the things that I came to
understand is that it's not appropriate
to make this too psychological.
People defend their belief systems,
but that's not exactly right.
You know,
we have a shared belief system.
Well it's sufficiently
shared so that here we are,
we don't know each other.
We're a bunch of primates,
we're in this room and it's
peaceful and no one's scared.
And that's pretty amazing.
And that means that we're
all acting out our roles.
So we're acting out or roles.
And we have an expectation with regards
to those roles and those two things
match and that's the important thing
and we'll talk about that a lot.
It isn't the belief system
or the integrity of the
belief system even it's the
match between the belief system and the
actions of the other people within the
belief system.
What you want to maintain is that match.
You want to act out your beliefs in
the world and you want what you want to
happen.
That's good thing.
You get what you want and you
validate your belief system.
Great,
perfect security,
but a lot of that is if we're
interacting even right now,
there's a whole set of expectations
that are governing what we're doing.
Like you don't want me to take your,
your little tablet there and smash it.
That would be shocking,
right?
You wouldn't know what the hell to do.
Right?
You'd be somewhere different if I did
that and you would know where you were and
that's another thing to know because
that's a fundamental difference.
There is a fundamental difference between
knowing where you are and not knowing
where you are.
I think it's,
in some sense the fundamental difference.
You can think about it as the distinction
between explored an unexplored
territory,
but you have to.